foreign
instead of kicking your kids out at 18
keep them home until they're 25 and
charge them 250 per month for rent when
they turn 25 give that money back to
them that would be almost twenty one
thousand dollars then they can use that
as a down payment for their future home
trust me your kids will thank you
just like Billy Madison
everyone in the room is no Dumber for
what we've heard oh my God
wow okay let me start off on the
positive note since I'm like all right
positive Penny over here I'm negative
Nelly this week so go ahead the idea the
motivation the concept of hey help your
kids save and wonderful let them have
some money for a down payment yes
absolutely yes absolutely secretly doing
it by forcing them to live at home and
pay rent and then to Keeping a Secret
account that you're gonna yeah and then
suddenly here it is no because no no on
many reasons
we're not mad at
I'll speak for me I'm not mad
grown adults living with their parents
for a period of time if there is a life
transition that is happening you've
moved to the city where they are and you
want to live there for a bit uh what
whatever it is right there are reasons
and again great reasons for adult
children to move back home for a period
of time right and not for this nebulous
oh I'm just saving money on rent 25. I'm
going to just keep going yeah no no no
for a period of time with an end date
very specific all of it because there is
such power when you're a young adult
when you're 22 23 and you're having to
figure out the world
there's just date I mean there's
something in that dignity there's this
idea that I have to Now problem solve
and I can't just you know fall back on
my parents and those lessons and skills
that you learn through problem solving
are what you lean on when you're 30 and
40 and 50 and through the rest of your
life so if you it's like
um
I'm gonna teach you how to do to bench
press and I'm going to get under the
bench press bar and I'm gonna push it up
for you and then you help at the very
end and then at the end I'm gonna tell
you clap for you tell you how strong you
are if you're robbing your kid of is
um strength yeah like the the steps you
have to take the day in and day out
stuff I mean it's just it's a long-term
game and I'm all for I'm all for Rachel
not only going home for a season that's
great yeah I'm also if you're have have
put yourself in a position if you've
gotten lucky in life if you've taken
care of your money and you've handled it
well
I can think of no more awesome gift than
at my kid's wedding to hand them a set
of keys or to say
I I got you a house for Chris like for
for your wedding or whatever yeah or
your down payment for your home I would
love to do that yeah it'd be amazing to
be in that position to do that but I'm
not going to trick you that's right and
I'm not gonna like reverse you know you
live with me for seven years till you're
25 and then I'm gonna sneak 20 000 but
that just come on that just doesn't work
I know so again the concept of helping
your kids
understand money and letting them save
all of it yes we are all for that but I
mean it's kind of a secrecy or the
trickery or the like and and they're not
even into your point I'm like they're
not learning to save they think they're
paying rent so then when they go off on
their own at 25 they have no like
ability to know how to delay
gratification because they haven't been
doing I'd rather sit down and teach them
how investing works and if they wake up
at 25 and they've chosen not to put 250
in an account yeah
um then that's the choice they've made
that's right that's right and there is
such a fine line with enabling oh yeah
we talk about it all the time and a
blessing right because like you said I'm
like yeah if you have the ability and
your kids are at a place where you feel
like yeah emotionally they can handle
it's not going to damage them to do
something crazy like buy them their
first house or a down payment on their
first out like right like you could do
stuff and we talk about changing our
family treats that kind of stuff because
if you're if you don't ever have a
mortgage and you invest your mortgage
payment what would have been you're
changing your great great kids life
changes their kids I mean like yeah the
ball keeps rolling which is a amazing
and that's part of the freedom we want
that money isn't this thing that is so
burdensome burden burdensome here you
know in our in our life and but again so
what's the balance of that John versus
it bleeding over into
I don't even want to say entitlement
it's more enabling this is an unpopular
sentiment and and we we do it innately
but then when the the higher the stakes
get the more dramatic we get about it uh
one of my kids I got two one of my kids
I can say hey do you want some ice cream
and they'll be like yeah it'd be awesome
and I can give them one scoop and
they're like yes
if I give one of my other my other kid
like hey you want some ice cream
I will find them digging through the the
mini marshmallows at 2 A.M like right
and so one kid introducing sugar in a in
a in a certain context is enabling I'm
making a bigger mess one of my kids can
handle it so I think enabling the
balance is have I trained you and taught
you and have you demonstrated the
character to handle what I'm about to
the the gift slash burden I'm about to
hand you because it's both yeah can you
handle this and if you can't I love I
love you enough to not do that right and
so it's super fun to give something as a
parent it's not fun to withhold but the
right thing to do is you're not ready
for this
um then I'm not gonna do that okay so
let's talk about like a realistic
situation if there is a parent out there
and they're like yeah I have two grown
kids one can handle it one can't
do you give one in this extreme example
of a house like let's just go extreme do
you give one a house and one not I mean
the way I would frame that was since
they were little I would say
um you are making choices
and if you choose this and this and this
then you're choosing to enter into this
right yeah and often parents will say
like if you talk that way in this house
you're out of here
I'm not going to weaponize my
relationship with my kids in that way
what I will tell my kids is if you
choose to be disrespectful to Mom you're
choosing to leave and the house doesn't
work well when you choose that similarly
if I have an adult child who's
the same as we tell people from
California yeah but houses just cost
this much math is still the same right
and so my adult responsibilities are
still the same no matter how hard the
conversation is if I have an adult child
who I have to look at and say you've
made these choices I so therefore you've
opted out of this blessing I was going
to put in front of you and
I'm not going to hold and I took this
from you I didn't get no you chose you
opted out and you're an adult and you
get to do that yeah this is where we
found ourselves yeah yeah now if I'm
gonna use it for like you're coming to
all my Christmases or whatever
yes that's a that's a power move and
that's a whole other pathology right a
whole yes a whole other thing there yeah
yeah so I think that that balance is one
that I think a lot of parents ask and
want to know as you start to raise your
kids and it's like yeah how do I how do
I give them blessings and we even talk
about this in our house and we have
little ones seven five and three but
it's like
there's a point that yeah we want to
enjoy our lives and go to Disney World
or whatever the thing is and have fun
but also there's a a normalcy that we
want to create that's not that right so
at Disney World I think of somebody that
there's I think of somebody like um
let's take LeBron James whose son is an
outstanding basketball player or one of
his sons is
because LeBron James is so good at
basketball in in the NBA
it doesn't give his kid a pass on
learning all the drills right and so
there may be better coaches there may be
better access all that's great his son's
still got to do the hard work and so if
I am in a different financial position I
I've got more money than my parents did
when I was raised great the lessons that
my kids have to experience and learn
stay the same throughout it right yes
it's still consistent because they're
still going to be off on their own and
life is going to be there whether you
like it or not so training them and
building that up in them so that they
can survive the world is what's